Leah Remini takes a tumble on Mondays  Halloween themed episode of Dancing with  the Stars there was definitely a fair  mix of a tricks and treats Leah Remini  was interviewing Val Chmerkovskiy and  Tamar Braxton after their performance  when this unexpected moment at work  never gonna dance to your full potential  right reach your full potential like I  never you know what turns out the  culprit in the creepy clown costume was  Sasha Farber one of the dancers in the  truth  he wrote to lea on Instagram saying it's  Halloween week it had to be done love  you  the actress didn't seem to mind that she  tweeted lol - a few fans and joked that  after falling her knees were a little  sore but when we caught up with Val  backstage he wasn't laughing and not for  the reason you might think I'm  disappointed man disappoints she grew up  in Bensonhurst Brooklyn and I expect I  expected her to be a little tougher than  that